[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what's going on guys jake here from joke
world today we're doing a video reading
your comments on some of the community
polls starting off with you're starting
a podcast and can pick any producer who
you got
young jamie from joe rogan experience
nadav from your mom's house and two
bears red band he's on kill tony and
used to be on jre and then you got lee
from the church of what's happening now
and other 12 000 people voted on this
young jamie had 57 of the vote nadav at
17 red van only at six and then lee had
12
which surprised me a little bit i
thought lee would come in first or
second actually but i guess it depends
what you're going for 57 for jamie
seemed like a lot of people wanted the
production by far probably the best at
googling and actually helping out with
the podcast but if you're looking for
someone to catch a buzz with have a good
time laugh a lot i would have picked lee
let's get into your guys's comments now
young jamie with dave's laugh and lee
science level of high uh yeah i mean
that's pretty much the all-star team
because if you think about it jamie's
probably the best producer and dove and
jamie would be the ultimate duo nadav is
the best choice would be the most fun to
work with see i don't actually know
about that nadav does not seem that fun
to work with i mean he laughs at a lot
of stuff and it adds to the clips but i
don't know if nadav is really that fun
to work with i feel like tom and bert
are always getting so mad at him and
christina p seems like the only one that
has his side really in any situation
like nadav is always like actually
beefing especially with tom it seems
like and i know that like it's funny
like it it might just be a bit but
sometimes they seem like actually pissed
native his laughs are the best and his
googling skills are unsurpassed
his googling skills suck like okay this
is called nadav is googling official fan
video
what was that
that was uh that was the intro
yes
i loved it
what's that all about what are you doing
well you know we did a couple long ones
in a row for you you know christina has
been requesting for me on the side to do
it a little shorter you know one one for
two for you one one for her
is that not okay
oh my god
i loved it can you say something
dude thomas pissed in the meantime i'll
look up some like you pull it up will
you celebrity gossip go to news right
here get rid of oh we go open a new page
go to google news
to get nightmare out of there
no no no no no no stop stop right there
stop right go back go back go back just
get it clear get it clear get it clear
[Music]
[Applause]
that's
[Music]
is
i've never heard him talk back to his
boss like that
i'm not talking back to tom like that
you can't handle the truth that's what
she said
read my lips no
new
axes oh welcome
welcome to your mom's house
what the [ __ ] is this yeah that was
terrible did you
you didn't like that
are you serious
what was that you talked last week about
how you wanted like a little more
innovation and stuff and you wanted you
know you wanted to innovate with the
intro i thought that meant you wanted to
go in a different direction yeah but
that has nothing to do with your mom's
house really yeah
no new taxes
you
it doesn't make sense for the list
wasn't that jack nicholson from
from a few good men i don't know where i
got it from you can't handle the truth
oh yeah that is where yeah yeah but we
don't even play that that's not a drop
on the show nadav you know but it's
aggressive you know we're trying to
it has nothing to do with the show okay
you can't handle the truth that's what
she said
read my
lips
that's what she's
that's what she said that's the best you
can do that's like an office joke that's
what people say around the xerox machine
it's sounding better this is a mess
dude that's funny they get so pissed at
him
good for you hey good for you
yeah i don't know if i want to die
if i want like an actually good podcast
um all right i mean but these are good
podcasts
so it is i i do see that it's all
nightmare news i hate this one
yeah this guy said i just want the dog
to laugh at my jokes that's basically
the only reason that you would pick
nadav what did he come in 17
out of 12 000 votes so yeah 17 of people
are taking him for the laugh in the
background but any real production value
i'm going a different direction probably
with jamie i love how red bands scored
lower than other that is very funny it's
pretty impressive that red band has been
learning how to produce a podcast for 10
years that is true too like red band did
kind of start all this podcasting stuff
he is he's a legend in in the game you
know he was there for the first joe
rogan episode he's doing kill tony now
um but he's just
not
he's not who i'm gonna pick
but shout out red band
that's
sick don't want him
not going to pick him but
shout out red band i'm looking for some
more love for lee
lee has been trained like no other gotta
get the flying julie that's what i'm
saying dude leah has so many good
moments but the thing that i'm wondering
about with lee is can he only really be
you know controlled by uncle joey like
if it was me and lee hanging out would
it be nearly as entertaining because i
feel like a lot of what makes lee so
funny or seems so fun to be around is
that joey diaz is constantly messing
with him like dosing him he's out of his
mind which is hilarious
watching him with joey but if it was
just you you and lee sitting there and
he thinks he's in outer space and i
don't know if that would really be the
same because they obviously have a great
connection let's see this lee video joey
diaz gets upset at lee for staying
inside let's see i mean it ain't that
[ __ ] hot but i'll tell you yesterday
there were some moments you could not
sit outside listen i love being outside
i love the sun i don't i hate that
indoor [ __ ] [ __ ]
you you're depressed get vitamin d
vitamin d
is the best [ __ ] thing in the world
for you a couple minutes in the sun i
know but
joey sun cancer you know it's cancer
sitting inside four [ __ ] walls
breathing the same [ __ ] oxygen okay
that's [ __ ] cancer you go outside you
sit under a tree you get close to the
[ __ ] roots it's making chlorophyll
you whatever the [ __ ] you suck by that
tree
you do some dr belisses you get a little
vitamin d
things change i [ __ ] change whole
days with 10 15 minutes in vitamin d
it's [ __ ] amazing how people actually
scared
of a little bit of [ __ ] sunlight i i
you know i get up in the morning first i
do is walk on the balcony i want to see
what the [ __ ] cracking i got to get
some air
i want to breathe whatever the [ __ ]
out there you see what happened the
night before was windy you know
something were you ever self-conscious
about taking your shirt off because i
always used to be and there's a huge
difference for me between being outside
and being outside with your shirt off
what do you mean who needs to go outside
with this shirt on i'm talking just go
outside and get air and get oxygen right
away you want to be [ __ ] tarzan
nobody wants nobody was talking about
the beach and i'm not saying like who
gives a [ __ ] about the beach i'm not
even talking about the beach you're just
saying random walking yeah the beaches
get caught to the beach no that's drama
i'm talking about leah's just always
asking the dumbest questions but they're
funny that's what i'm saying like i
would want to have him around and just
say some of the things that lee says
make no sense
i haven't seen this one before
joey diaz epic rant about lee eating
subway plan for tonight where you gonna
go tonight i got nothing we're gonna go
and get some cheeseburgers how much how
many calories you got last time
like you're not gonna eat tonight
this don't bring nothing to you oh yes
it does like a thousand calories
[ __ ] count at night i'll tell you why
because i had to take a sleeping
politics in the morning so i didn't wake
up till noon so i had one subway
sandwich today and then i had two other
podcasts and so he's a thousand he woke
up an hour ago yeah pretty much
so yeah so i still have something left
because every time i get this high i
have to eat why'd you eat a subway
sandwich you didn't go to big mice
after everything we went you didn't go
to jersey mice you're back at that dump
i had two i i had three podcasts they
had to go to the gym there's some jersey
mice around the corner
what happened
it was easy
why would you go to subway you go that's
it it's over no more subway you're a
jersey mike's guy now okay that's it
that was pretty good that's it
no more subway that's the rule in the
house no more stuff i don't want to hear
that [ __ ] you're a jersey mike guy get a
regular sandwich no chips and get a diet
soda and i'll be fine i do it all the
[ __ ] time tuna with a little onion
hold the vinegar with a little mayo
you're fine they got the turkey nice
turkey real turkey with provolone cheese
you put some lettuce you put some
mayonnaise salt and pepper it's a
beautiful [ __ ] sandwich
no more subway guy that's it you're a
man you're a church [ __ ] evaluator
you're the [ __ ] guest host of the
chair how are you eating that disgusting
[ __ ] people are dude okay subway is good
first of all also jersey mike's is
really good love j mike's that is funny
that he's so adamant about him only
eating at jersey mike's though like
that's what i'm saying i don't know
obviously i wouldn't be bossing lee
around like that i think maybe the charm
of lee as the producers this
relationship with joey
but
j mike's is really good though you got
to get the 13 everything's way or a hot
sandwich you know what's funny subway's
probably more healthy than jersey mike's
i would bet but
dude
jersey mike's is good i might have to
get that today
or the big kahuna cheese steak the
chipotle cheese steak but subway is so
consistent subway is spicy italian at
subway you get some mayo all the
vegetables but jersey mike's you get it
mike's way with the oil both are good
i'm getting a sub today they're looking
at you don't want to [ __ ] no more of
that [ __ ] you got jersey mice right
around the corner bro right around the
corner why do you hate america
he hates he loves that pepperoni he goes
in and he gets that pepperoni from in
there i get pepperoni from the deli
counter jimmy john's is also pretty good
and i feel like that's the healthiest
just just by vibe i don't know the stats
or anything but jersey mike's seems
like greasier but you know
tastier jimmy john's is fast though but
it's all cold i like a hot hotter sub
what's the name of your al qaeda cell
well you got pepperoni at the [ __ ]
subway yeah with not sometimes
you are a jersey mike guy now you're
from the east [ __ ] coast guy you got
to start acting like you gotta start
eating top-notch food no more silliness
for you there's a busload of
grandmothers that just perished because
of your insubordination [ __ ] you're an
easter egg so yeah dude i would love to
have lee as my producer i think right
now i'm between lee and jamie and i know
that joey like raises his voice at lee a
little bit but he never seems to
actually get mad at him the production
seems great young jamie is like really
good at his job obviously but he never
adds anything into the conversation
unless he's reading an article he never
like makes you laugh or like he's like
oh yeah that was a good young jamie
episode like no one's ever said oh yeah
that was a great young jamie episode he
really shined in that one he's good at
what he does but he doesn't really add
anything to it so that's why i think i'm
leaning more towards lee like you can
make the best moments of lee lee cracks
me up sometimes he's actually funny
jamie is productive and efficient so
right now i think my power ranking is
lee
jamie nadav and then red band one fire
and ivan gets rid of from
congratulations podcast with crystalia
that is another good producer they have
some funny moments too jamie is the goat
no question about it when google want
you to come show their people how to
google things
you a monster i don't
i don't know what that means ben avery
getting some love on here there's a few
ben avery comments yeah i didn't put
them in the poll because i just thought
that these four were probably gonna get
more votes than ben but there were a lot
of comments for him i could see ben from
the tim dillon show the most successful
podcast in austin yes or yes what a
great job that he has i would love to
have his job you just sit there and
basically get a free
improv stand obsession from tim dillon
every day like that's a pretty sick gig
uh homeless pimp homeless pimp lee all
day ben avery one fire and even gets rid
of again i mean ben avery who's the
producer of the biggest pockets in the
world by far
that's true it is the biggest one in
austin and the biggest in the world uh
bad friends producers george and fancy b
whatever
whatever they're okay
they're good they're good
they're okay joe rogan
don't understand the question
joe rogan again
joe rogan again dude
what um that's not the question but yeah
joe rogan can be your producer i think
that he um would probably agree to it
you should reach out probably instagram
dm and i'm sure he'd get back to you
pretty soon if you want to start a
podcast and joe rogan is your producer
he would probably drop everything to do
that so
let's see let's find another one ben
avery ben avery ben avery benevolent
avery
wow rogan again there it is i really
underestimated ben avery which i will
never do again
how did nadav get a single vote lol
that's what i'm talking about no nadav
hate but i mean
a little one fire and i even get rid of
do have a few votes and i really liked
listening to chris get mad at those guys
i thought that was pretty funny i don't
know how entertaining they are i've
never heard them speak let's watch this
clip
video of crystalia mad at his producer
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up my babies it's episode 121
of congratulations and welcome it's
brought to you by the cash app crazy
[Music]
now look we start off i'm best because
one fire said i was good to talk and i
wasn't good to talk because the theme
song wasn't over yet did he ruin the
beginning of the show yes is it okay yes
will we get back on track
yes
and a professional talker so will it be
okay yes it will be fine is he still
on fire
absolutely
but my babies were here and we're doing
it and it is episode 121 and it is
[ __ ]
you know what i woke up today and i was
like i was like look maybe we should
push this podcast to wednesday because i
wasn't feeling it i wasn't feeling it i
woke up today and i'm still tired from
doing all the early flights even though
i don't need to because
my routing was supposed to be easy
enough to where i wasn't doing the
flights early because the flights
weren't too long so i didn't have to get
up too early and my agent said it was
going to be all good and it wasn't all
good because they were only connecting
flights unless i took the early flight
which was a straight shot so i ended up
taking the early flight anyway and
therefore i am [ __ ] absolutely
goddamn exhausted now it's okay
i don't know how much longer because it
woke up this goes on or if he's gonna
yell at him again does one fire still
work for chris julia i'm not even sure
but i do like him but i like i said i've
never even heard him talk i just think
it's funny when chris gets pissed at him
um i guess that's what i think is funny
about all these people is when the
comedian gets pissed at them any of them
would be a great choice i think i'm
gonna finish my rankings with
lee number one jamie two who did i have
three
nadav three i guess
uh
okay official rankings
here we go
lee one jamie two i'm gonna go
red no ah okay
lee one jamie two ben avery three
red band four one fire
just
it didn't work out you should stay at
your job
being the producer for three of the most
successful podcasts in the world thank
you guys for watching this video go
check out the community section on our
channel and you can go vote on those
polls and leave some comments we'll do
some more videos like this so if you
want your comment to get read on the
channel go check out that community
section also if you haven't already we
got a few more free stickers left just
hit me up on instagram or email for some
free stickers we're gonna have some some
joke world stickers in a few different
countries which is pretty cool too no
matter where you live we're gonna look
into getting you some of these free
stickers and thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
it's a dark place
[Music]